this is a Fox News Alert another
shake-up to president Trump's cabinet
the president just announcing that he is
replacing Veterans Affairs Secretary
David Shulkin the president just tweeted
I'm pleased to announce that I intend to
nominate highly respected Admiral Ronnie
el Jackson MD as the new Secretary of
Veterans Affairs in the interim
honourable Mike Wilkie of DoD will serve
as Acting Secretary I'm thankful for dr.
David Shulkin service to our country and
to our great the veterans and Jesse did
this come as a shock or surprise to you
it did not because we've been hearing a
lot about this for the last month or so
this was an Obama holdover Shulkin and
we all know what happened at the VA
under President Obama where I had these
long waiting lines and bureaucrats were
given bonuses for service that they did
not provide while people died waiting
for care that they never received so
this guy was brought in and apparently
was supposed to have cleaned things up I
don't know how effective he was
including that up there the president
campaigned on taking care of the
veterans and was very proud to sign a
new VA accountability bill where it was
more easy to fire people that were
underperforming and that's a good thing
but I think there was some travel issues
with him he might have run afoul of the
administration on some ethical issues
with respect to that and he had to go
the president's not going to keep some
guy at that agency that's not a hundred
percent behind the veterans and-and-and
can't afford to allow any sort of
perception out there that the president
is not taking care of the vets that he's
so deeply valued and we know the new
guys that the star of that Trump is in
perfect mental and physical health press
conference and I think I speak for the
table we all really like and admire that
guy we really do and I feel very good
about your chances and my chances to
live a long and healthy life with a very
similar meal and diet plan that's
feeling that maybe he is asking Ronnie
Jackson to head over to VA because he
had instituted new diet rules it's like
you know I know how to fix this yeah
Ronnie Jackson is an amazing medical
doctor he's well respected by many
administrations
he's been there I think for three or
four of the last presidencies
and he also he I think it's very
important for president Trump and what
you see as he heads into the second
phase of his presidency on the personnel
level is that he really wants to have
people there that he personally trusts
and he really knows this doctor very
well now and trust him and knows that
dr. Jackson will do a great job taking
care of the veterans and the other thing
that's was really strange is all these
weird rumors about the political
appointees at the VA trying to usurp the
secretary and a lot of crazy things
going on barricading himself in the in
the office but but as a public servant I
think that he has done a decent job and
I will move on and it's good to have new
blood at the VA all right but there you
go okay great all right skipping scrubs
you shaking more cabinets than an Ikea
truck driver I guess he is going to be
free from my show this week always the
bridesmaid okay I know the president's
having trouble hiring a lawyer but has
it occurred to any of you but that mr.
dr. Jackson has no background in
handling a bureaucracy or reform maybe
that target man oh gee yo maybe he hires
he hired somebody that he knows
personally and maybe it I don't know
maybe it's a payoff for that good he had
someone in who had experience dealing
with bureaucracies and management
Shulkin and that didn't work out so well
that it's not the other personal doctor
from before what what do you mean
remember during the campaign oh that guy
the guy here in New York that was that
guy was something I like that don't
everybody widely admired he's gonna do a
fantastic job and he's in touch with the
veterans who served in the military
because I know about him I've actually
prepared and know about him and
fantastic I don't like
know about because I heard that his name
was under consideration or in a normal
administration because you know let's
admit we're not in normal today there's
you know but let's just say in a normal
administration they just bring in the
guy who happens to be the president's
doctor with no background in this area
no experience no relationships no
network doctor so and he was very good
apparently right but he was under a bunt
but now he's not because he's president
Trump song everybody in wait lines had
tons of bureaucratic except aside guy
that was killing everyone remember all
the veterans that was before I know I
was the administrator of all these
hospital the hospital's had trouble let
me tell you this again is overblowing
veterans have a high opinion of the
veteran's administrations medical
services but again we be gets into the
media and you say oh it's terrible there
they just want better service and what
they deserve the veterans I know they're
not so psyched on it they think they get
sent home with the bag of pills and
become addicted there's an argument
about whether or not they would they
would get better treat and some people
say privatize it send them out to
regular but they don't want it everybody
thinks they get better service from the
Veterans Administration but I'm all for
it I hope it works
I'm just saying would you really hire
somebody with no experience I don't know
you're second what hexxit don't you say
Pete was my death he was your guy I know
you got I got knock it off literally the
next round minute round